dear mr. Cameron I'm writing this from
the heart from my cottage in moorland
which my husband and I have worked so
hard to make a comfortable home the
waters are not in yet but I can look out
of every window and see that the drains
are no longer doing their job the rena
at the bottom of the garden is full the
road here is flooded across right next
to me and it is only a matter of time
where that i'll have to move out I fear
for our house and possessions but there
is only so much that one can do to
protect them I do strongly believe that
this catastrophe which has so badly
affected our hard-working farmers and
their livelihood as well as the
villagers here this could have been
avoided if help had been given sooner at
Christmas and as and as well over the
last few years that's when we needed it
please help us all for the future dear
Mr Cameron I write this letter as flood
water is slowly approaching our home the
majority of our village is already under
water as is the rest of the Somerset
Levels
why oh why when we had the floods last
year did you not start maintenance then
I can't believe that you were naive
enough to believe that it would not
happen again
the money you are setting aside will
this also include plans to reimburse the
poor souls who have lost so much will
consideration be given to reducing our
contribution to overseas aid there are
many in our village wondering about the
saying charity begins at home and
finally I understand that today you
visited Birmingham was this an important
meeting more important than coming to
see us here in Moreland